[Music]
[Music]
here are the lot Sukhdeep seeking his
car no money glaciers are rushing
streams wearing away the uplifted land
here is land dreadful it is quiet you
serving not as a source of water but as
the last receiver of West natural
abundance wield a spectacular plant and
animal life that distinguishes this
place in the country
[Music]
[Music]
the Everglade is the largest subtropical
wilderness in the United States and the
only one of its kind in the world it is
the only wetland in the world that is
primarily nourished from the atmosphere
not from melting IceCaps
or mountain stream it provides habitat
and food for 45 mammal species 350
species of birds a multitude of fish
species and at the same time it provides
drinking water for over eight million
people as Lake Okeechobee overflows in
the wet season the water passes through
hundreds of diverse habitats as a
slow-moving shallow river running
through Everglades National Park and
into Florida Bay before there was a
Florida Native Americans inhabited the
area bringing agriculture and fishing
and lived harmoniously with the
environment some of their descendants
are members of the Miccosukee and
Seminole Indian tribes today if you can
imagine being here 300 years ago this is
what was sacred this is the creator's
creation that nobody can duplicate our
people the Miccosukee after the during
the Seminole Wars our people hid in the
Everglades and the Everglades provided a
safe place for our people to live it
provided food shelter
in order to create more land for
construction of roads and cities man has
trained the life-giving water from Lake
Okeechobee by diverting its natural flow
of emptying into nearby coasts
well the Everglades has been changing
throughout its whole history it's just
the rate of change over the last eight
hundred years or so has been so much
faster than the pace of change skin it's
a deeper history and that's mainly
caused by all the canals that have been
put around the Everglades to divert the
flow of water off the land and over to
the sea and this has had an additional
effect by creating an overabundance of
saltwater these changes directly affect
the flora and fauna of town eventually
it will impact all the residents of
southern Florida the water quality needs
to be improved if Lake Okeechobee is the
heart of the Everglades system and I
believe that it is that his way was
designed to be that the water quality
coming into the lake has to be addressed
we've got to have cleaner water so
therefore we can disperse cleaner water
to the estuaries and hopefully into the
Everglades it was not until the nineteen
seventy that environmental awareness in
America connectivity the formation of
the Environmental Protection Agency an
indisputable evidence of endangered
wildlife study began a wave of national
concern and Earth awareness in as early
as the 1970s and late 1960s notices were
already going out from the state that
there was a lot of pollution in these
waters and so our people here have been
impacted where we were given notices you
don't want to drink the water eat game
or do any hunting or take anything from
this environment more than once a week
so we have been dealing with that since
the late 60s and 70s but now what you're
seeing is not only is it the Indians now
it's everybody else who's going to be
impacted a strategy was formulated and
debated for several years eventually
bringing about the calm
hence of Everglades restoration plan
this 30-year study was authorized by
Congress in 2000 as a plan to restore
preserve and protect the South Florida
ecosystem while providing for other
water related needs at the region
including water supply and flood
protection the Everglades can shed light
on dynamics have the whole world cared
for that in the world is watching
Everglades restoration is the world's
largest most expensive and in some what
they most important ecological
restoration project and so the world is
watching the Everglades and what happens
here has much to tell us about the rest
of the world over the years many new
stakeholders have emerged intense
debates over the where and how the water
is to be distributed who is to pay for
it and who will manage the logistics of
maintaining this vital resource our
waged in courts to this day it affects
everybody in South Florida
you know the tribal members the
non-tribal member the whole part of
South Florida is affected
you know whether whether they accept it
now or not it will affect them in the
decades to come so what is there to do
to increase public awareness and
stimulate change first thing I've asked
the public to do is do their own
independent research and get their own
independent answers then if they want to
contact the Weston officials I will tell
you based on my lengthy background of
government that we give as much
attention to your communication as it
deserves well I think the best thing
that we can do right now is make sure
that every time that we talk about an
environmental issue we bring back the
reality of the
importance of the individual in this
environmental issue usually we tend to
talk about environmental issues and will
lose hope and we either blame the
generation before us or we leave it up
to the generation that is coming after I
would forget that we right now as
citizens we have a role and we can call
our representative and we can like we
are we can take that first step for any
policymaking there are three major steps
needed to begin to restore the
Everglades water conservation better
water management and controlled urban
growth
education is the key to communication
understanding and appreciation of the
South Florida Everglade from the airboat
rides in which people experience nature
firsthand the public forum to connect
common interests and community citizens
must have constant vigilance on issues
proposed bills and elected officials the
world is watching as the issues
surrounding the culture of water are
turning global we need to be asking
ourselves all of us what is our
relationship to this what is our moral
ethical and sort of shared cultural
obligation when it comes to water I
think solving the Everglades and
restoring the average way is every bit
as much a social and cultural project as
it is a scientific one a political one
or a legal one we must plan for the
future to ensure that future generations
will have a beautiful home in which to
live
[Music]
you
[Music]
you